Am I early?
I came on time as to avoid
the cats and dogs outside.
So no one dressed slutty
and old-timey?
Oh, I did! And I'm already
having fun!
As much as I loved the bike
ride over here--
Oh, by the way, I, uh...
I got a new bike.
I know, I moved it.
What is going on here?
I thought you said this
was mandatory, Timothy.
That's what the letter
that I got said.
I got a letter, too.
Who would hang chains
on the bookshelves...
that aren't chaining
anything up?
Welcome to the
Murder Mystery Escape Room!
Oh, are you serious? Come on,
this turnout sucks butt.
I invited like a hundred
and a half people.
You did this?
Yes.
All right, you guys wanna
get out of here?
Yes.
Of course.
Wait, no, no, no!
I promise it'll be fun!
Wait. Timothy, you're gonna
be Professor Grapes.
Oh, I've always wanted
to be a professor.
You can be the sexy maid.
Ooh, I love sex!
Billie, you can be
Miss Charlotte.
No, that's a stupid name. Stop.
Dean Arnold, you're my favorite,
Colonel Mayonnaise.
No, no, no, no, I'm not.
And you're Mrs. Pussywillow.
Oh, I love pussies!
I have a Scottish Fold.
Okay, I think I speak
for almost everyone here...
when I say that no one's
into this plan.
You have 60 minutes to figure
out all the clues...
and unlock all the locks...
including this lock
on this very door...
or else you'll never escape
the room!
Your time starts now.
No!
Don't swallow it, you idiot!
Oh, my god,
she's choking on it!
What are we all yelling about?
( SWALLOWS )
Oh... oh, they make that look
so easy in kids' movies.
How are we supposed
to get out now, Gene?
You figure out the clues and
then you use the-- you use the--
Right... right.
( THUNDER CRASHING )
Agh!
Somebody do something!
Oh, I thought that would work.
Wait a minute... Windy! Windy
has a key! Where's Windy?
( BOOKS FALLING )
My office! Windy! Windy!
Oh, Windy, thank god
you're here.
Do you have a spare key?
[MAN]
Windy left already.
Do I know you?
Agh!
I mean, yes... you do.
Um, you recommended I not be
hired by your colleague.
Do you work here now?
Did you hire him?
I did.
Great.
Welcome to-- welcome aboard.